Rocky Point, Long Island 1933 Guglielmo
Marconi and David Sarnoff visit the
birthplace of broadcasting. Radio's first
castle was this rustic shack. In 1921 radio
fans are all earphones listening to
a pioneer station WHN. Crystal Set
explorers hear such performers as
Miriam Battista, child movie star.
One of radios trailblazing announcers
introduces what he calls a little peach
from a Broadway show. The peach poses as radio
gets called everything from gag to gadget,
at best the plaything in the fan but fate is to
make radio a power in a world of peace and war.
Herbert Hoover, Secretary of Commerce
in 1922, finds infant radio facilitates
news gathering as do many others in high
public office. Henry White comes to a WJZ
microphone with latest news in sports in what
is then the latest in broadcasting studios,
but growth radio is swift from toothpick antennas
about these beacons of broadcasting the Fort
Jefferson tower and Arlington, Virginia
here's one that's 600 feet high. Radio
waves over ocean waves. In 1923 one of the first
American overseas broadcasts is heard in England
by Captain West of the BBC and relayed to all
England by a wondrous thing called wireless.
Chicago's Edgewater Beach hotel houses this top
studio of its time. Drapes hide microphones,
glass walls shut out unwanted sound. Here are
among the first motion pictures of broadcasting
members of Chicago's Civic Opera singing the
quartet from Rigoletto. Here's Florence Macbeth
and Angelo Minghetti. Famed Uncle Joe Cannon
becomes a fan as 19-year old Marion Talley in
1926 sings in New York for a radio audience of 16
million listeners. Radio is big-time here to stay.
In the marine room at the Edgewater Beach
Hotel, broadcasting branches out on one
of radios first remotes the famed Oriole
Orchestra plays for an unseen audience.
Police discover the power of broadcasting from
mobile units alarms are sent out to officers
equipped with receiving instruments.
It's in trial stages now, but it works
A mounted policeman gets instructions by radio. In
1923 baseball goes to bat via radio world famous
Graham McNamee describes the doings of the World
Series. It's a hit for the runner and for radio.